as you're saying it's a big big venue
where a lot of people are sitting so the
air quality there was oh really bad yeah
and only boys you know yeah they want to
call it right
you learn that all right well game three
started david what are we seeing it's
another sicilian defense this time
slightly less cagey than the first game
of today it's the open sicilian jana
panetti going on the attack early and
this last porn move by white pushing
upon that white cheep on forward shows
his aggression
but magnus reacts instantly this is the
height of opening fashion this is one of
the most trendy uh lines most trendy
variations in chess right now we saw
trade of knights white uh black pushing
a pawn forward now white is the first to
castle black really needs to catch up on
peace development though if you look at
all of black's king side pieces all of
the pieces on this side of the board
they're still asleep about napomiarchi's
choice is that uh we're actually
following a game that nils grandelias
played against magnus carlson just look
at the black pieces
he needs to bring them out he does he
leaps out with the black knight and
white just guards two pawns with this
last push one thing that's super
interesting is actually you know when
i've looked through the games i always
see one name that stands out that magnus
is uh has been following and it's always
jordan van forest he was his second in
the world championship match magnus has
been really impressed with the young
dutchman yeah we talked about air
quality but jorgen van forest i think he
was a breath of fresh air for the uh
magnus team at the world championship
match so they're probably actually just
preempting that expecting that in
advance and stepping back with his queen
it's basically the world championship
match just with lower stakes lower price
money slightly lower rated players but
just as much on earth
for number two scandinavian player
and uh yeah it's going to be a battle
that's this going to be that's going to
ruin the friendship you're too nice to
vancouver i would do anything to be
different no no no no maybe a launch pad
for a future attack by white's knight or
white bishop he doesn't do this he plays
the safer option and uh talking of
targeting pieces the white knight was
the target now the black knight on the
side of the board is the big big target
and i guess then it's looking good for
him so far this could be the game he
makes that comeback yeah i just think a
great opening choice
when you need to win it's nice to have
these imbalances and look at this
actually exactly what i showed on the
board has just happened black did try
and challenge in the center this is
thematic in the sicilian
when you're on the black side you want
to explode open the center of the board
but now after the bishop hit the knight
it was defended and this exchange this
trade favors white the black rook in the
corner would drop off
so okay he doesn't even feel the need to
block it up maybe being more ambitious
napoleon he brings his knight in already
going for this isolated doubled weak
pawn on the edge of the board and from
there he'll jump in towards the black
king
yeah it's sharpening up and i can
actually see that this has kind of been
analyzed in july 2021 but it didn't look
good for black
okay so it's been analyzed this would be
a real disaster from magnus carlson
walking into a variation that is known
and okay the evaluation by saying black
is fine-ish now
but from a practical point of view
unless he's 100 sure
i think he's going to walk into danger
this black king stuck in the middle it's
going to be stranded there for a long
long time well i faced a very sharp
opening against the karakan and i didn't
know my theory and i lost
very quickly and
what happened yeah
jan playing a very surprising move
actually hitting the black queen with
the white bishop but this can be blocked
by a porn move i'm wondering if the
evaluation bar will correct itself yeah
i mean this still feels super sharp and
to me yanaponnichi may be still in
preparation so okay yeah that evaluation
bar let's ignore it for now it's going
to swing and swing and swing as it has
done throughout the whole final
yesterday and today um yeah so human
move yeah it's a very human move i think
we'll see some fireworks and there are
some ideas behind it i think jan is
actually getting ready for some really
surprising sacrifices uh i think black
is in big practical trouble okay he does
drop back with his queen uh now he wants
to trade off so black's queen
threatening to capture the white queen
but white's queen is just gonna move out
the way coming but he was like okay i'll
go for it the pawn can be pushed in the
g file and my knight is on the f file
but that's okay like i wouldn't be brave
enough to do that and it was a
theoretical draw i know that now
is that something you've actively worked
on since your first over-the-board
experience if magnus plays okay he just
brings his rook across firstly as ivanka
mentioned queen takes pawn was a bad
move because now the bishop would
actually hit the queen and hit the rook
a nice sacrifice which didn't work this
one he made this night check after a
couple of minutes of thinking
but it was the wrong decision and
maybe just at that critical moment
investing another two minutes would have
helped him uh find a stronger idea and
now the evaluation about really hating
white's position it can even sacrifice
okay and there you go the rook comes
into the second rank wow it's the best
move but it's also the most obvious move
so of course magnus was going to find it
and magnus just
one chance he's
he was given one chance in the last game
he seized it now one chance in this game
so far he's seized it and
that's why he's the world champion he is
ruthless and meanwhile okay jan jumping
in with the queen that's brave
allowing blacks of rooks to come into
the position there is a threat from
white and it seems like it happened to
napoleon twice yeah so magnus just
offering the trade of queensland okay
white's going force back and then some
queen checks to follow up i'm not sure
that works instead he just brings his
rooks down how do you defend i mean can
you just ignore everything and just go
queen takes bishop and
yeah i think maybe he could have tried
that but i think there would have been
some checkmating ideas
um if that had happened so white
dropping back the bishop to defend the
pawn in front of the white king but
delivering checkmate at the very end
he's not gone for that i've gone for it
but maybe finding a different uh
different strong path magnus in the
current position taking this bishop and
now after king takes he's jumping in
with the black queen
still strong but
your move winning on the spot katrina i
think and now the white king is able to
hide in the corner maybe and uh jan is
he living to fight another day or has
magnus got a follow-up here
i think he's going to do katrina's idea
there we go there we go same idea and
what a hard fought and fantastic final
by anna pognati we know he's been
under a lot of pressure a lot of things
has been on his mind it must have been
hard to focus he has played some
fantastic games
but there it is
it ends here magnus carlsen winning two
games today he is the winner of the air
things monster after an incredible final
with a great janna pomnyacci by magnus
carlson showing
his genius in this final we've had
incred